in 2018 Vladimir Putin personally
inaugurated this bridge to Crimea and
even drove a truck across what was
billed as a major infrastructure upgrade
for the Occupy peninsula
now satellite images show the extent of
the damage on the bridge the only link
between Crimea and Russian land
partially collapsed after a major
explosion which set a train on fire and
killed several people this is a bridge
that was a symbol of Russian power so
inflicting such serious damage clearly
is taken by the Ukrainian as a morale
boost very little is known about the
blast but security footage and verified
social media Clips offer clues that can
help us understand what happened there
let's take a look at videos taken just
before the explosion Russia said it was
investigating the role of a truck in the
security footage verified by the news
agency's story full a truck appears to
explode close to the epicenter of the
blast
however engineering and defense experts
say that the vehicle is unlikely to have
been the primary cause of the incident
in that case there'll be a hole in the
middle of the bridge and not just this
collapse of two spans they think that
the exposure most likely came from under
the bridge the various theories it could
be a manned or unmanned boat or it could
be Commander divers placing shape
charges on pillars of the bridge and in
this video just as that truck drives by
you can see something that resembles the
nose of a ship appearing under the
bridge just an instant before the
detonation the fact that the surface of
the road appears to be unscathed in
aftermath images also suggests that the
attack could have come from underneath
according to military analysts and
Engineers the Damage Done to the bridge
can also help estimate the amount of
explosives used in the attack so
demolition experts we've spoken will say
that uh if this was that professionally
by placing shape charges at this support
structures of the bridge it wouldn't
require a huge amount of explosive
several sort of trash can sized
explosive charges
so who's behind the blast Russia blamed
Ukraine news
a Ukrainian presidential advisor
responded to Putin on Twitter calling
his accusations too cynical Ukrainian
officials welcomed the attack on social
media but didn't claim responsibility
experts agree that if Keith managed to
pull off this operation it shows a
dramatic increase in its ability to
counter Russia's Invasion this bridge
was one of the most highly protected
structures in the world this is an
attack that is hundreds of miles from
the Ukrainian lines so it would have
required deep infiltration uh into
Russian territory and a very high level
of secrecy the bridge is a strategic
artery for the supply of fuel military
equipment and food to Russian troops
fighting to hold ground in southern
Ukraine
Russia said traffic on the bridge was
partially restored quickly after the
blast and fairy links were resuming
still many civilians were left stranded
and images showed long lines of cars
trying to leave Crimea the Kremlin had
warned of severe consequences should
Kiev try to strike this infrastructure
it is an escalation but again it's not
the first time that Ukraine has struck
either in Crimea or infrastructure
Targets in Russia this significantly
reduces the capacity of the Russian
forces that are fighting South Ukraine
and trying to fend off the Ukrainian
offensive
two days after the bridge attack Russian
strikes hit at the heart of Kiev as well
as other Ukrainian cities in moscow's
biggest missile barrage in the country
in months